April Kelleher is a citizen of New York
City and survivor of the dollar flu
virus she was in Manhattan the day that
the quarantine was put in place but
thanks to a Survival Guide she was able
to fight back against the disaster that
flipped the city into a state of anarchy
and mayhem all of these events have been
documented in the eCos and scattered
pages across New York City but also
through the division companion novel New
York collapse
keep watching to gain an idea of what
life was like in Manhattan through the
eyes of the civilians stuck at the front
lines of the biological attack that's
written mankind
[Music]
you
prior to the outbreak April received a
gift from her husband Bill this gift was
in the form of a book a guide it was
called New York collapse included with
it was the note to a on her birthday
because you can never be too paranoid
about the world coming down around your
ears but if New York City collapses I
know we won't babe
you and me me and you the world begins
and ends there read on and you'll be all
set when the zombies come love much love
all the love B although it was taken as
a joke gift April had no idea how useful
this guide would become December 3rd
bill worked as a biochemist for a
company in Manhattan called the sequent
biotech group or SB GX on the day
Manhattan was put under quarantine April
got worried and went to visit bill at
work taking the subway
April bought the book with her as
something to read for the journey but as
she walked down the road towards his
office she witnessed her husband running
out with a couple of his co-workers
there were men behind him
men with guns and at the same time two
cars pulled up inside these cars were
more men with guns
April quickly decided to duck down and
head out a sight while a gunfight broke
out between the two groups everything
was over as quickly as it started the
first car drove past and she could see
that one of them in the backseat was a
colleague of bills and he was covered in
blood
April ran to the building and found Bill
slumped against the bike rack did in the
crossfire he'd taken two bullets to the
chest
suddenly the men who originally came out
of the building drag Bill's body away
and into the second car
well another held a gun on her they were
wearing all-black military-style
clothing after the shooting the crime
scene was taped off in a coroner's van
took the bodies away April called the
police about what she had witnessed and
to try and get some more information
about what had happened to her husband
but a detective told her that there'd
been no report made on any firearms
incident in the area she hung up the
phone after staying a scene for a while
she decided to go home but upon arriving
at the subway bill signs posted up
everywhere saying that there was a
quarantine in effect and that the trains
had been cancelled
she was trapped on Manhattan Island
April only had a handful of positions on
it including some cash angry scared
confused and unable to go home April
hits to her friend Eva's house where she
plans to hang out for a few days or
until things calm down a little
December 4th more people were getting
sick people on the TV and radio are
telling everyone the usual stuff like
avoid crowds don't panic if you're sick
stay home
and don't go to the hospitals unless you
really have to nobody seems to know what
the sicknesses but it moves fast and a
lot of people have already died from it
quarantine on Manhattan is now in full
effect the National Guard has blocked
off all bridges and tunnels leaving the
island
[Music]
December 5th April begins to start
questioning the details around her
husband's death who were these people
what was Bill involved in and why did
they leave me alone either consoles are
telling that everything's gonna be okay
she tells her that she doesn't think
it's a good idea to look into Bill's
deaths just to contact the police but
she's already tried then December 6th
utilities are starting to go down they
still have power
Eva's place but they don't expect it to
last talking to people in the
neighborhood the word smallpox starts to
be repeated although this is yet to be
confirmed by the authorities for the
majority this is just taken as nonsense
taking advice from the book
April avoids ceará bases as these places
are jam-packed with thousands of sick
instead she goes on the hunt for
supplies
there isn't any looting at this stage
just a lot of panic by those small riots
were starting to occur
December 7th
eva has become sick she is a fever and
his coughing fortunately they still have
power
so April is able to make some ice to try
and control the fever Sara promises that
there's a vaccine on the way and they'll
be distributing it door-to-door but they
never come December 8th
Eva's sickness worsens she has developed
blisters all over her body
the DCD is now sequenced the virus it
confirms it to be a variant of smallpox
at this point April begins to guess that
due to the quick infection rates of the
virus that it's actually a terrorist
attack and suspects that money may have
been the way it was spread December 9th
Eva has died from the virus
April attempted to contact her family
but by now the power was out and a cell
phone hasn't been going for the last
three days for now April wraps up Eva's
body in a sheet and leaves her in bed
[Music]
December 10th with the help of one of
Eva's neighbors April carried a body up
to the street duct-taping on our ID
there are rumors that Sara was going
straight to street picking up bodies
using refrigerated trucks and storing
them at the Hudson Yards April continued
to stay at Eva's house December 11th
police in the National Guard was sitting
up barriers and huge warning signs
saying to stay out of an area and that
no one was permitted to exit while this
was happening a riot broke out close to
getting caught up in a April hides in a
nearby restaurant after the right
disperses she speaks to someone wearing
a sara shirt who says there's a big
shelter and supply distribution point at
Madison Square Garden
April is suspicious of this because the
Survival Guide tells of how Sara prefers
to avoid big open spaces like this
because it can be difficult to control
the crowds this turns out to be a good
decision because later on the series
taking control of by a larger
again December 12th with no other
options
April continue deliver Eva's place April
was greeted by Shawn at her door Shawn
was one of Eva's neighbors that helped
carry out Eva's body to the street just
a few days ago unfortunately this time
Shawn was not here to help he pulled a
knife on April and told her to leave the
apartment April did what he said quickly
grabbed her things and left she was out
on the streets again against the advice
of the book she checked in with public
shelters to see if he no one had any
space to house her for the night she
eventually found one in the basement of
the church in the Hell's Kitchen
district it was crowded but at least she
had a roof over her head while in the
shelter she began to dive deeper into
the survival book after reading it more
carefully alarm bells started going off
she wasn't sure if it was the exhaustion
or the trauma of recent events but she
was starting to make connections
connections that shouldn't be there
things were heading far too close to
home the predictions were too specific
warning of a virus outbreak and even to
the point of explicitly revising to
avoid the handling of money at all costs
[Music]
you